thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a timely
wild ride with Stevo we've got the voice
of the Octagon Bruce Buffer and what a
legend he is plus UFC fans oof three
weeks without an event I would say this
is timely this is the UFC fix and man do
we get into it what a fascinating guy to
learn about his relationship with the
famous Michael Buffer who's his brother
known for saying let's get ready to
rumble I mean man it's just incredible
what a good guy what a great friend and
uh it's always a good time when I see
old Bruce Buffer it's always a good time
when I'm drinking liquid death too
because come on this is the greatest
company out there if you're not aware of
liquid death their name comes from the
fact that they are bringing death to
plastic plastic is destroying the world
man but these infinitely recyclable
aluminum cans are not destroying the
world this company is on fire man I love
it and they've got these new flavors
liquid death mango chainsaw severed lime
bury it alive the old standby regular
sparkling and of course the Mountain
Still Water ah I just can't say enough
about how much I love this company and
how crazy the deal is that they offer
you if you go to liquiddeath.com
Stevo free shipping on all of your
orders of water and or merch their merch
is hilarious it's awesome and water's
pretty heavy so for them to give you
free shipping is ridiculous you gotta
try these flavors you got to support
this company so one more time go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo free shipping on all of your
orders of water and merch and now let's
get into it
okay
Wendy Wendy Wendy
you are there you go good girl all right
so we uh we're recording we can dive
okay good
I've got little things for you here I
love it is that in the camera it is not
that is that is off camera
okay so we'll we'll get right to it
ladies and gentlemen Bruce Buffer ladies
and gentlemen Stevo
yeah man thank you so much for doing
this oh it's my pleasure Stephen come on
we've been trying to get this together
for how long it's been a while yeah it's
been a while now it's time right yeah we
it is time we uh we did your podcast a
while back yep and um that's the It's
Time Podcast the It's Time Podcast it's
on YouTube and all the you know Spotify
everywhere you can see these podcasts
yeah and that that was a blast while we
were recording your podcast I floated
the idea of you announcing me and my
fiance at our wedding right and you just
said dude easy done I'm there
I I love that so much man not only quite
your wish is my command you know that's
the way it goes yeah I love doing
wedding videos because like um you know
my Bruce buffer.com site I get I
probably do five weddings a week
sometimes wow except when kovid had died
out obviously people can have their
weddings and then all of a sudden it
picked up and now the weddings are
flowing and birthdays birth of babies
which is one of my favorites you know
coming out now
yeah it's all good yeah it's it's crazy
um we were uh watching various
interviews that you've done and man is
it fascinating that the thing that I
just thought was
most interesting is all these businesses
that that you've been involved in and
and
is it right that you you own
telemarketing companies yeah when I was
uh when I cut my teeth I went to college
and on the job board it said earned 350
to 450 a week uh selling over the phone
I had a kind of a gift to gab as a kid
right and I went in and they said um
yeah it's office supplies we need you
here at five o'clock I go five o'clock
in the afternoon they're gonna go five
o'clock in the morning and I lived in
Malibu and I had to get up at like four
to get there at five and we called the
East Coast all the way back and
um I was I became kind of the wolf of La
I mean I didn't cheat people like he did
in the movie I sold office supplies
paper and toner but it turned into a big
business I started my first company in
19 and when I did I left and 70 of the
sales force came with me because I would
close their sales and make them a ton of
money
the people I worked for got really mad
at me and sued me for a million dollars
when I was 18. now this is back in 1977
78 right wow and um that that was
ridiculous scared the hell out of me I
never was involved in kind of a business
setup like that so long story cut short
um I want going back to work for them
they made me a partner they paid me more
money and all the sales people came back
and then eventually I started and ran
different telemarketing companies I had
export import companies I ran
collectible gun shows did motivational
you know speeches even in my 20s you
know around and I started cutting my
teeth and I I spent time just being an
entrepreneur as I've always been my
whole life and I still do today but then
something really crazy happened as you
know
um my life took a strange turn an
amazing turn an exciting turn when
suddenly in the late 80s I noticed this
man announcing the boxing when Mike
Tyson made boxing really really popular
again and it was a water core
conversation on a Monday like the UFC is
and here comes this Debonair James Bond
looking individual
and I thought wow this guy's got it got
it together you know this guy looks like
a model he's traveling the world meeting
amazing people and doing what he does
and with the let's get ready to rumble
but then they put his name on the screen
and I said buffer and I'm like whoa you
know because I looked in every phone
book we didn't have the internet back
when I was intelligent and I saw every
phone book in the United States and just
as a normal habit you look up in the
white pages to see if your name is there
right right never saw it so I went
through like six months of calling Don
King's offices Bob arum wondering who
this guy is and lo and behold long story
cut short it was my long lost half
brother my dad never told me
um because he was married to my mom for
like 57 years before he passed and uh
you know together 57 years married like
50 plus and he never told me that when
he was like 20 years old before he went
overseas in World War II to do his duty
he married a woman and they were married
for nine months he came back a divorced
ensue but his son was born yeah and it
turned out to be Michael and Michael was
raised by foster parents how to Leave it
to Beaver lifestyle uh his mother passed
away when he was six and it was just one
of those things Stevo you know and then
later on in life we all came together
my dad contacted him they got together
for lunch and they got together along
famously then we all met I was basically
about in the area of 30 Mike was like 43
and then four years later even though I
was making great money I had a beach
house living the life of Charlie Sheen
Two and a Half Men minus the alcoholism
you know and um you know just enjoying
my life and I was making like I said I
was making tremendous money I had
nothing to worry about but I was burned
out okay I didn't I was waking up every
morning and instead of going it's time
to have a great day I was like oh [ __ ] I
gotta go to work you know I lost my
passion and my my want to do what I was
doing I was just in it for the paycheck
and I'm just not that kind of guy you
know I am but I'm not I'll cash it on a
Monday before anybody gets to the bank
but I'm not all about paycheck I'm about
loving what I do like you right sure
so
um he never trademarked that phrase or
did anything with it and I went to a big
fight of Andrew Holyfield and Riddick
Beau won I think was November 16 1992.
I'm not mistaken and I went back to my
room in Vegas because that night when I
watched Hulk Hogan and Jack Nicholson
and everybody jumping out of their
chairs and going crazy when Michael went
into his Rumble I'm like something's
here he's got a trademark this phrase I
mean he hadn't he hadn't even made a hat
or a t-shirt right and I went I
incessantly wrote three pages of notes
non-stop down on a piece of paper you
know put him on the NBA court football
field uh TV film make cartoons make
video games do all this and I said to
Michael in a meeting in so many words I
said listen I want to make you richer
and more famous than you ever dreamed
and I want to put this phrase on the tip
of everybody's tongue as part of
American culture beyond what you're
already doing in boxing we'll keep that
as the base and I'll build everything
out of that but to do that I need to be
your business partner if I make a video
game or you know we're Partners but as
your manager whatever managers get I
need to be your manager I need to direct
your career and uh it was probably the
best poker hand I ever played aside from
my way I got in the UFC that was the
second best poker
and with that being said we got together
and um
he had trademarked the phrase but not
properly could have been stolen from him
the way he did it you know because it
needed to be traded trademarked in
different classes as I'm sure you
understand
and I did all that and within a year I
had the first product out I used to go
to these conventions you know with toy
manufacturers and I you spend fifteen
dollars a promo kit a Kinkos putting
everything together you know it was
harder back then we didn't have we have
today right and I'd be walking with all
these promo kids under my arm and Hi how
are you I'm Bruce Buffer you know
Michael Buffer's manager let's get ready
to rumble it would look great on your
product you need to make this you need
to make this blah blah blah
deaf ears deaf ears deaf ears boom
talking keychain talking mug other
products came out but our big hit was in
99 we came out as one of the first games
on the Dreamcast video machine if you
remember that one and I created the
ready to rumble uh boxing video game
with Midway wow that was our we sold
like three and a half four million games
and this was back where they made maybe
350 games a year now they make thousands
a year right and when Dreamcast came out
um between my game the other nine games
released in the Dreamcast it did 97
point something million in sales in 24
hours and at that time made the cover a
variety or Entertainment Weekly I forget
what you was saying uh Dreamcast and
games make make entertainment sales
history in that 24-hour period I can
honestly say we were part at that time
historically of the most sales in the
entertainment industry ever done in 24
hours wow as being part of that that
group of stuff that came out on the
Dreamcast so I take a lot of pride in
that I mean obviously Call of Duty and
these other games have smashed that
figure sure but it's just you know that
kind of exciting thing doing that and
feeling that kind of passion for what
you do and love just kept fueling my
fire and I still manage your brother
still management to this day I mean
Michael's the legendary
I say greatest announcer of all time
we're totally different I never wanted
to be Frank Sinatra Jr I didn't want to
copy him everybody wanted to copy
Michael I told myself when I got in the
UFC if in three years I didn't create my
own style and recognized for being Bruce
Buffer that I would quit
and just continue to do what I do I know
I mean I'll always make money there's
always ways to make money yeah but I
wanted to do what I was passionate about
and that's what the UFC is all about
what were you doing for I mean you were
living in Malibu in the 70s sir yeah I
moved yeah just you moved out there to
Surf and it wasn't as expensive as it is
now or was it expensive and you were
kind of hustling it still well yeah well
what happened is that my dad he never
graduated high school but I would say
he's a borderline genius when you get
down to it read incessantly educated
himself and became sales manager and
vice president of Fortune 500 companies
and as a result we traveled we moved to
Dallas I was born in Oklahoma which is
kind of a drop-off he says I was
conceived in Vegas dropped off in
Oklahoma for nine months then we went to
Dallas was there for like three years
went to Philadelphia where all my
relatives are from my mother my
brother's born my dad was born in New
York
um there for a number of years went back
to Dallas for a couple back to Philly
you know it was great learned how to
fight in Texas learned to fight better
in Philly and and then as a young kid at
14 15 he says well we're moving to
Malibu right I felt like The Beverly
Hillbillies you know like moving to
Beverly Hills right but we were middle
class we weren't Rich by any standards
and we lived in trancus Canyon out there
and all the rich people all the movie
stars lived to the beach and Steve
McQueen was a was a very good friend of
mine for the last six years of his life
I served almost every day in front of
his house wow truly was Mr cool no
question
and uh yeah I did the life of Baywatch
surfing uh met Chuck Norris's fighting
Partners I was I was uh studying Judo in
Philadelphia
um got in a lot of fights and you know
as a surfer because Surfers are very
Territorial and we trained martial arts
we surfed and we fought and loved life
you know fights in the water or on the
beach they would start sometimes in the
water and they obviously get out on the
beach it's all going to come together
right there try and being ground
impounded or ground and pounding
somebody on the sand I knew what
grounded pounding was before I ever did
it on a mat yeah yeah so it's uh kind of
like a
what's the movie with Keanu Reeves Point
Break Point Break yeah I live the life
of Point Break but I never robbed a bank
you know the boaties of this world I
grew up around a ton of these guys you
know it's just the beach party
everything you saw in the movie you know
we did it's so great man
um and uh with the UFC
is uh your first
announcing job the first fight you
announced was 1996. yeah it was February
16 1996. it was in Beaumont Puerto Rico
uh and I again this is a poker hand okay
what I did was is that I had Michael in
the UFC and UFC six seven in ultimate
ultimate when the UFC came on the scene
my job as his manager was to get him in
the biggest events happening in the
world well the USC was the fastest
growing pay-per-view at the time and it
was a spectacle it's gone from spectacle
to sport it was Bloodsport back then
what styles the best you guys know this
right so I got Michael into it and then
uh when I got him in the first one in
that time which was in uh
uh Casper Wyoming and UFC 6. they had
him say Robert Meyer was the owner at
that time had him say uh if it's not in
the octagon it's not real right well he
was doing the WCW which was huge and you
know wrestling is huge today staying
Hulk Hogan all but in those days when
Hulk Hogan hits him in the face 15 times
right they wanted you to think it was
real and you know this is everything and
all that goes with it well you know your
face would be hamburger okay because
they're pulling but they get hurt a lot
I have so much respect for wrestlers
they go through so much nothing but
respect for professional wrestlers and
all they do they're hundreds of shows a
year and being on the road it's a tough
job yeah but I knew I was going to get a
phone call
and lo and behold that Monday I get a
phone call so is the call was something
effective what are you doing you know he
announces for us why do you have him in
that because you know they don't like it
right right I said look I signed a three
fight deal his contract allows him to do
this the way it's written it's not an
issue let me have him finish three
fights because obviously Michael loved
the wrestling and this was so much and
he was they were paying him huge money I
got him a big payday in the UFC but it
would have been hard for him to continue
with it so he did his three and out and
then I went after him and said look you
need a buffer in the Octagon now granted
I had not announced except one time we
went to Kellogg Michigan and did a small
kickboxing show right and Mike and I
were talking and I said bring your tux
you know cut your teeth get up there and
do one so I went out and did one
it'll never forget after I announced the
winner the guy the winner came up to me
said thank you for announcing my name Mr
buffer but I got to tell you I've been
waiting two months to hear your brother
say my name I disappointed the guy
because it wasn't Michael it was me but
that's where I cut my teeth and I
thought you know I really like this I
wouldn't mind traveling the world like
James Bond living this kind of Lifestyle
so I went to the owner and I said look
you need a buffer in the yacht gun I've
got media and I did I have the media
contacts okay you don't people are
scared of you right this is still a
spectacle people are scared of this I
even talked to ESPN that ESPN back then
didn't even like the name the name was
scary Ultimate Fighting Championship
today ESPN just paid you know a billion
or two dollars to have the TV rights
it's amazing how things change
so I said in order for this to happen I
need to be the announcer I need to grow
with you as the announcer and I will do
everything I can to get you media
contacts which over time I did I got
them on Jay Leno Jimmy Kimmel you know I
would get all this stuff and I don't
want any money for it I never asked for
a dime I just did it because I loved
what was happening
but it felon deaf ears okay and then I
thought how am I going to get into the
UFC so I got a videotape from a a real
kind of Neanderthals great guy named
Scott the pitbull for Razzo 6-1 300 plus
pounds hands down to his ankles you know
that kind of thing brutal fighter and I
sent it into the owner and he said okay
great let him fight because that's the
kind of guys they were looking for
partially right then and so they brought
him down to buy him on Puerto Rico at
UFC uh eight and when that happened
you're allowed as a manager to fly down
I probably would have flew down with him
anyway I'm on my own tickets but took
advantage of that put my tuxedo in the
bag when I got there I said Robert I got
my tuxedo in the bag give me a shot let
me announce this so he let me do the
prelims and that's the first time I ever
announced in the octagon and I look at
it now and it's kind of like no no no no
no you know everything has its
evolutionary process you got to build a
tool
so then I thought okay I did a halfway
decent job and I'm pushing giving in the
same pitch I'll stop in their offices in
New York you know take them out for
drinks whatever I could do to ask for
the job I come from the business if you
want something you got to ask for it
ain't that the truth ladies and
gentlemen if you want something in life
you gotta ask and let me tell you
yesterday my buddy Vinnie says man I
slept on the bed at tight box packing
that's my warehouse in San Diego got the
best night of sleep I've ever had I've
got to get one of those mattresses from
helixsleep.com I said that's darn right
you do because it really is the best
night's sleep you're ever gonna get let
me ask you how old is your mattress how
riddled with dust mites and bed bugs is
it how disgusting is it is it time for a
new mattress because you can get the
best one for you by going to Helix
sleep.com slash Stevo you take this
super simple a two-minute quiz they pair
you up with the best mattress for you
and or your partner and you get up to
200 off any mattress on their site plus
when you get one of those mattresses
they give you two free pillows telling
you
it's time to step up your sleep game
just ask my buddy Vinnie these
mattresses will not steer you wrong so
get on over to Helix sleep.com slash
Stevo take the two minute quiz enjoy the
up to 200 off of any mattress they've
got and take those two free pillows
because man they're the best pillows in
the world I got a whole closet of them I
love it so get yourself that new
mattress and let's get back to Mr buffer
don't wait for things to happen make it
happen right sure so
um it fell on deaf ears they hired
somebody else and they call me and said
oh well the announcer's uncle passed
away we need you in Alabama in two days
three days to uh do UFC
um 10.
and um can you be there I was in the
hospital with my mom she just had a very
serious operation my mom's as our moms
are everything to me right so she's in
she's like Talia Shire Rocky you know do
you remember when when Rocky's wife you
know she's having a problem she doesn't
want him to fight and she goes into a
coma and he's beside her reading to her
everything so I'm on the phone I go look
guys I'm with my mom in the hospital I
gotta call you back after she could hear
what we're saying and I hung it up and
she looks at me and she goes that's the
call you've been waiting for isn't it
and she literally did this she goes go
that's great all I could hear was
you know that's always ringing in my
ears and it's like the whole montage is
happening and me getting ready for the
show and boom I go down to Alabama I
announce the show I think I do a fairly
good job considering my my experience
um but no they didn't hire me right so
they went on to hire somebody else
and the guy was good voice a little
nervous in the service shuffling messed
up a couple names gave me enough fodder
to call him up and still keep saying I
want the shop I want this job I want
this job then they called me six months
later give or take and they said listen
we're gonna we're doing a show with
Warner Brothers called friends this was
the second season of friends it was
episode 23 or 27 I forget
John Favreau Tank Abbott Big John
McCarthy you're all in the show this is
the UFC is doing friends the friends
made a TV show called friends the
ultimate it was the ultimate champion
and it was John Favreau was Monica's
boyfriend and he was he was a eccentric
on one episode it was a one-off on one
episode okay but it focused all around
the UFC and so they wanted a voice over
announcer initially
and then they said um they called me and
they said listen they want the real
announcer so
they're going to come down and pick up
tape and audio of you Warner Brothers
came down sent a runner down you know
how this thing goes the Runner comes
down to two I get a call five be on the
set tomorrow morning at six rehearse all
day you're co-starring on friends the
biggest comedy on TV right well that
gave me more fodder to give him a call
so I called the owner I said you're
going to be on the set I said we got to
meet at lunch right so I'm rehearsing I
meet him at lunch I said look Robert
this is the biggest comedy on TV this is
the biggest PR push UFC's ever had I'm
co-starring as myself as the announcer
it's time to make a decision I feel like
a girl waiting to be asked to the prom
and nobody's asking me to the prom and
I'm going to ask you one more time I
want to be a renouncer I want to grow
with you I will help you build this
sport I will help you build this event
I'll do everything in my power outside
of being an announcer and believe me
there's no better Workhorse you're going
to get than me to get this done but I
want to grow as the announcer to get
this done and we'll grow together
best poker hand I ever played in my life
Stevo best poker hand I ever played and
you said this is the last time I'm ever
gonna have the last time and it would
have been I would never would have asked
him again a year and a half yeah they're
trying to get this job
so boom there we go I've done every show
since then until about 10 or so years
ago I don't know exactly they brought in
a second announcer because there's 42
shows a year right it gets hard to do
every show uh his name is Joe Martinez
excellent job it's all good you know and
um he represents the sport well but you
know what that's my octagon it really is
I walk around with the USC on my chest
like Superman and I'm so proud of it and
I'm very humble about it because it's
all about the fans and the fighters the
show is not about me but you've been
there I will throw every ounce of
passion and energy I'm probably gonna
die in the Octagon I'm probably gonna go
it's tough right down and I couldn't
think of a better way to go to be honest
with you either that or hit by a great
white shark when I'm surfing you know
that kind of yeah so you're still
surfing once not as much so used to you
know it's uh the big waves and all I got
no ACL on my left uh name the cartilage
is going down in the shoulder so I got
to be a little careful the the heavy
spots that I've gotten myself into
surfing North Shore Hawaii and a lot of
places I've served in my life right but
I'm still an athlete I still train every
day still yeah I'll I'll go at it with
anybody you want it's unbelievable
um when uh
when you do the UFC how long is your
contract for
uh usually when they you know contracts
can be
usually I like signing like you know a
five-year contract three-year contract
because you know you're always looking
forward to the renewal right I mean I
gotta believe it the way that it's grown
over the last what five years even like
uh it's really the last since Dana White
and the protitis took it over when we
got on Spike and that great fight they
had with Stefan Bonner and Forest
Griffin yeah where the ratings went from
for people if you understand what
ratings are on TV they went from a five
shared or something like a 12 plus share
by the time the main event came on Spike
was brand new and I honestly can say I
mean I feel it that we made Spike and
Spike made us and that was the that was
the key launching pad that was The
Ultimate Fighter reality show the
reality show they were millions of
dollars in the hole The Story Goes that
uh Lorenzo Fertitta called Dana said
it's time to sell it you know they're
like 44 million or some crazy amount in
the whole
and Dana got an offer
and then however it came down the
fertittas and Dana and everybody rolling
the bank were all decided to roll
millions of dollars on a TV show called
The Ultimate Fighter which turned out to
be a huge hit big time Big Time and that
don't hold that oh that yeah you know
you can sorry to sorry now you can see
me squirm around
just hold it like that when you hold it
like that I'm getting static in the
thing okay yeah that's I've sorry to cut
you guys up oh so it can see me sweating
over here I've been trying to figure out
what the noise is I won't be able to
disable this one so that's not gonna
happen it's not doing it now okay good
and and we're not record this is
recording onto its own track so
great don't worry a dripping sweat uh
technical difficulties folks yeah sorry
about that has that ever happened in the
UFC like when you're announcing or what
do you do when there's technical
difficulties uh you know what like I'm
sure that you can attest to you know
when you're performing and something
happens even if you screw up if you know
in my case if I said the wrong name
which I can count in my hands thankfully
you know the major scripts I've had over
28 years come February whoa um you just
gotta roll through it you got one time I
was looking I was in Brazil
and sorry to take away from we were
talking about before but I was in Brazil
and I was looking at Mario yamasaki
who's a Brazilian uh gentleman and I'm
looking at him I go and you're and your
referee in charge of the Octagon is Herb
Dean and what I'm saying
I know I'm saying it wrong you know but
I just let it fly go out that's yamasaki
the controversial judge who uh loads and
certain fights go on a little bit no
that was Steve mazzagati ah okay
yamasaki was another got it every
referees had their own listen it's one
of the hardest jobs thank you for
correcting me has Mark Goddard ever had
one
no I think every there might be question
marks at times was it a KO was it right
to stop but you know the beauty of the
UFC is in boxing at one point there were
like five or more deaths a year okay
there's never been a death in the U.S
correct yeah there's been two maybe
three deaths I'm sorry to say in the
sport of mixed martial arts we're
reported medical or a Russian situation
that uh event that happened in the UFC a
lot of broken egos a lot of broken bones
a lot of torn ligaments but never um
not on my shift and I hope it never
happens that's because the the lighter
gloves and the fewer rounds well that's
true but also you know in boxing the
boxing glove was made to protect the
hand correct not the head right and when
you're getting hit with the 12 ounce
pillow or you can refer to it or the 12
ounce glove 14 ounce eight ounce
whatever
remember these guys have lost and women
have lost so much weight right the day
before their brain Cranium areas are not
full of fluid whatever the situation now
a day later they're going in taking that
punishment but it's not so much to fight
it's the sparring and everything that
goes on leading up to the fight it's a
lot of head trauma unboxing yeah and
there's a lot of head trauma now in UFC
but I think as a rule and the way the
way the refs work it's a safer sport if
you can say that although to most people
it looks much more brutal right you're
dealing with 40 plus weapons versus the
two Marcus of Queensbury left and right
hand right I mean these these men and
women are super men and women I mean
they can come back at you with anything
you throw at them that's superhero stuff
right I have a theory that uh
the the UFC is safer because of the
gloves and I I compare the UFC gloves to
boxing gloves and the analogy being the
old school leather football helmet to
the new
football helmet
guys weren't leaving with their head
when they had a little bit of piece of
leather on their head so you didn't have
CT back then yeah now you've got this
humongous football and modern football
helmet where you can essentially crash
your head with impunity and some people
are crashing their head so many times
that and that's what the the boxing
glove does it allows you to throw your
hands with impunity and yeah
yeah exactly and and remember the brain
is rattling inside right okay it's tough
it's crazy people talk about concussions
I mean you know when I was kickboxing
heavily and all and I was gonna try to
go for one profile just say I had it but
I got concussed twice during my training
and the doctor looked at me and he said
and I I was slurring my speech the
headaches I mean I was having all the
symptoms when I got this last concussion
I'm sure I had many concussions before
from you know being slapped by big waves
and also you know from fighting and
stuff because I think whenever your head
gets rocked to me that's a concussion
yeah to be honest but then you're
diagnosed with the concussion and he
says stop he goes if you continue this
then you may have a problem in your 40s
I think the word concussion breaks down
to uh Latin for head hit
if that's the case it stands the reason
yeah yeah like kind of like percussion
is like uh you know the concussion is
hit and I think Khan is head that's
interesting yeah so anytime you hit your
head it's a concussion
yeah so you you grew up fighting a lot
and and I heard a podcast
no not the elevator fight but there's
another fight that you got into and
you're and and what struck me about that
you're like listen when you're in a
fight you're going to want to stay as
close as you can to Chuck Liddell and
I'm like oh that one yeah but I'm like
you've been in so many fights to where
like you know you know what you want to
do when you're in a fight like you know
you got to stay close to Chuck Lidell or
you got to do this and that I'm like
what kind of light you've lived a pretty
crazy life you're you know the most
interesting man in the world oh well
thank you I appreciate that I'm not
trying to act like a tough guy he's
tough in their own right we all go
through situations but listen my dad was
one of the toughest men if not the
toughest man I ever know he got me and
more fights and introduced me to more
girls than any best friend
I could go into Story upon a story about
story he was making me tough from Fox he
was a Marine drill instructor servor
World War II Korea hand-to-hand combat
the whole bit he was teaching me
fighting at five years old before I went
to school in Philadelphia preparing me
for what was going to happen as an
example he told me if a guy comes up
behind you and Azure from behind pick up
your foot and stomp them right on the
show me right on the point because pick
up your foot and stomp him right on his
foot as hard as you can right lo and
behold
weeks a few weeks into going to school I
got you know called jumped or whatever
by the local young gang or whatever it
was guy comes up behind me wraps his
arms around me and they're gonna do
whatever take my lunch money and I
stopped that guy's foot and he cried
like a baby and I thought to myself I'm
gonna listen to everything my dad tells
me from now on you know wow that kind of
thing uh
here's the thing you know there's
certain rules about fighting obviously
you never want to get in a fight I've
seen people heard if not killed in the
street you know it can happen so quick
you don't want to you won't avoid it at
all costs you're in a bar fight first
thing you do I've been in a big fight on
an after party at the UFC all hell
breaks loose you get the wall right
behind you because you only have to pay
attention to three areas not the one
behind you you never know when this
bottle or anything's gonna hit you in
the back of the head right and that was
a very funny night one time around one
fighter turned around he was going to
pop me and he goes oh sorry Bruce and he
runs back into the fight you know one of
those crazy situations
um I just
don't take any [ __ ] okay I mean you
stand up for what you believe you put
your hands on me I never want to cause a
fight but you know it's my loved one my
mom whatever nowadays I walk away you
know unless you
oh [ __ ]
um but I'm 65 years old there's no
reason for me wow that's so crazy man
all natural yay what's your workout
routine what do you do you said you work
out every day what do you do fantastic
all right thank you I appreciate that uh
listen it's 75 what you eat and 25 how
you train right and as far as working
out staying flexible
um cardio weights circuit training you
know cardio cardio cardio cardio right
um core strength everything just all
around I mean I do I have a great
trainer guy named Tito Raymond I can
train on my own I got a gym in my house
during covet I've made sure I could put
a really nice gym in the house to train
stay in shape I don't go to the gym
anymore uh golshin was my Haven
um I train at his house or I train at my
house and I train on the road and I
could go into many different training
methods but you know there's all good
things to do I mean yoga moves are
important stretching is important just
overall you know just don't pump iron to
get ice cream muscles you want to work
from the inside out you want to work
your microfiber and everything and you
know really build good muscle From the
Inside Out core strength the whole bit
and you're going to need an isotrain to
compete now I train to get older
and longevity I mean you fly just as
much as we do when you land are you
going straight to the airport or
straight to the hotel and working out
and getting the blood flowing usually my
routine is that depending on when I land
is get to the gym and do cardio just get
just get on the machine just get your
blood flowing it's not about the weights
I do plenty of weights and stuff when
I'm home on the road stretching
cardio wow I'm sorry to cut you off oh
it's all good I you said um that your
your partner Kristen that's that's your
partner professionally
yes right uh she's she's my partner in
buffer Enterprises and she's been
working with me now we've known each
other for
obviously about 28 29 years
um she's been working with me now for 25
of those years started out
um as my assistant
and Michael's of my assistant grew into
you know vice president of company we've
built so many Avenues of business
together which I have gifts for you here
I want to show you something I love it
um and she's my right arm you know she's
she's the greatest part together us in
our home offices we probably do more
business than most small to mid-sized
corporations
and without her I I'm not saying I
wouldn't be where I am today but
honestly without her and the way we work
I probably wouldn't be where I am today
let's just put it that way it's valuable
and you know as a best friend and a
partner what more trust Factor can you
have in life man I'm also Godfather to
her son she married a great guy and uh
Rupert who you met you know I call him
my nephew or whatever so it she she's
also family yeah you know been there for
me through thick and thin
I think it says so much about somebody
when they have relationships
particularly professional relationships
that endure for decades like yes
um you know we um
Scott Randolph here we've been working
together for nine years close to a
decade coming up on a decade nine years
well see that's a big that's a big move
itself and that's awesome I would say
the same exact thing you know like the
The
Avenues of business that we've created
together uh it's it's wild we're
absolutely a a little Corporation in our
own right that's awesome and uh best
friends Partners but it's great because
you both share passion you both love
what you do yeah and I'll say it about
you guys too listen I know you do well
right it's not always about the paycheck
you're living a lifestyle for sure yeah
I don't even know uh
what you know I I don't even know
and if there if there's some kind of
amount of money or like I don't even do
anything with with money you know the
more money you make the more you work
you know like there's nothing you know a
lot of people the more money to make the
more they want you know it goes in all
different areas but whatever you know
right yeah I just I think about it too
like what if uh
what if it's some point you know I I had
so much money and like and I didn't work
like that sounds miserable to me I'm
like a shark I gotta keep moving that's
doggone right you gotta keep moving and
you gotta stay on top of your diet now
I'm gonna come clean I don't always have
the best diet which is why I'm so
grateful for athletic greens ag1 this is
the most delicious and comprehensive and
convenient daily nutrition out there
come on one little scoop in a pint of
water in the morning you're hydrated
you're ready to go you've filled in the
gaps in your diet and let me tell you I
got some gaps in my diet okay this stuff
is loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals Whole Foods sourced
superfoods adaptogens probiotics this
stuff is not only as healthy as it could
possibly be it's also delicious it's
great for your gut health for your
cognitive abilities for just your
nutrition I mean honestly it's uh it
sets you up for the day and what a
delicious way to start your day so go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo and for your
first order you're gonna get five free
comprehensive convenient nutrition packs
a daily travel pack five of them and an
entire year's supply of immune boosting
vitamin D
it's because they love the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast check this stuff
out go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo jump on that deal now let's get
back to the buff
yeah you know and um people say when are
you gonna retire when you do this my god
when you talk about the UFC the one of
many Avenues of work I have it's a as
people say it's like the greatest job in
the world I mean you're traveling the
world like James Bond you know you
whatever you're just going and doing
your thing and captivating hopefully
captivating you know 15 20 50 000 people
in the audience watching my favorite
sport I'm so into fighting and you know
being respected by the fighters and and
you know and again the great fans which
also feels for me too the UFC fans mixed
martial art fans are probably the or
some of the greatest sports fans in the
world as loyal as they are so who's not
going to enjoy that right why would I
want to give that up you've taught me
that you just never get bored never get
bored and the moment that my passion
wanes right it's not there then hey it's
time for me to retire I don't want I'm
not going to phone this in I'm not going
to phone it right I won't do it I just
don't I don't want to just do it for a
great seat at a fight in a paycheck I
can't do it because I love it when
you're traveling and you guys know this
when you're traveling when we do and and
when as I do internationally I'm sure
you do too
people you might think it's all great
and everything but the novelty wears off
after a while it's not it's a lot of
work It's a Grind It's a Grind yeah yeah
it is is there a certain level of EXC do
you notice the difference between like
these Arenas that you're doing and then
if you go to Australia or New Zealand
you do a stadium or I mean is there
what's the biggest crowd you've ever
announced for uh I've announced in front
of uh 55 000 people 55 Toronto on uh
Canada uh where I went out and um a week
before I was at a poker turn on a big
poker player and look I happily say I've
been World ranked and you know I've done
very well in tournaments and stuff even
have a poker room in my house for games
and stuff like that
um Molly's games oh wow but uh with that
being said
the week before I was at a tournament
and I got up during the break and I took
a walk and my ankle rolled and a dip in
the carpet right two-day tournament okay
I made the second day I woke up the next
morning my ankle swollen this red is
full of blood I ran to the hospital had
the blood pulled out got a pair of
crutches went back to the tournament got
third place 130 Grand you know go home
but I'm like oh my God I got to be in
Toronto in six days I can't walk I
wasn't able to walk until Thursday on my
own feet right then I got on the plane
on Friday went to Toronto I got in the
Octagon that night for the biggest show
in history sold out in 20 minutes fifty
five thousand five thousand George Saint
Pierre and Jake Shields the main event
all through the show my adrenaline got
together I did everything I do I turned
you know I do all the stuff I do jump
the whole bit and then I go to George
St-Pierre and I'm like George rush and
then George always walks out right and I
always Bunny Hop back like a foot and a
half or two as I say yeah right so
here's the thing I'm not even thinking I
Bunny Hop back bad ankle wobbled my knee
exploded I severed my ACL just as I was
announcing Pierre so like George Rush
and I was like oh my God it was in pain
and I saw the video and you can see me
like hopping to Herb Dean or whoever you
know put the microphone underneath and
you see me hop out on one leg
and uh Big John McCarthy comes out to me
because I think you just blew your ACL
and I did right so the funny thing is I
was doing a movie Here Comes the Boom
two weeks later we had shows almost
every week and about it took about two
to three months before I could schedule
a two-week three-week period where I
could get my ACL replaced so I I had a
special brace made and blazing with UFC
like from here to here I would wear
under my tuxedo pad and I worked for two
or three months with you know basically
no ACL
and um then I'm going to get an
operation on and usually you need a
month or two before you get on the road
again well in like three weeks I was
back on the road a little buffer light
but I got it done and a guy named Dr
eleatrosh Who did Tom Brady's knee right
your hand yeah
I'm like that too
um who did Tom Brady's knee when he
severed his ACL so he did my knee now
I'm in rehab and who walks into rehab a
week later but George St Pierre so I
blew my ACL announcing him he blew his
ACL a month or so later in training got
operated on albatrosh we both wound up
in rehab together that's kind of crazy
isn't it yeah yeah he fought you had you
had to tap out and then he did the rest
of his fight with with the torn ACL yeah
and how crazy is that you know speaks to
Adrenaline yeah it's crazy then there
was another time I given two knees to
the UFC there was another time
um we had three fight nights in a row
you know these are like eight hour days
right sure so three full shows three
days in a rows never been done before
the night before they had a lip sync
contest so they asked me would I do it I
thought they wanted me to host it but
they wanted me to do a lip sync right so
okay I'm game for a little fun so I did
Rebel Yell by Billy Idol right but when
Billy walks out he always does a little
jump so I was on this flimsy type stage
at the place we did it at I walk out I
did a little jump the stage kind of gave
a little bit and my knee I felt the same
explosion I felt in this knee so if you
Google like Bruce Buffer blows knee at
lipstick contests of all things
um you see me do a three minute
rendition Rebel Yell but my knee
actually separated two or three times in
the first 45 seconds I could feel it you
know pop twice at least and you see me
fall down on the on the side and I'm
still doing the thing right and then I
get up because there's a point where
there's like a guitar solo and I get up
on the you know and I'm doing the guitar
so the whole bit so then I'm like holy
[ __ ] I broke my I don't curse that much
but holy [ __ ] I broke my AC I blew my
ACL again right so I go to the doctor
the next morning get the MRI oh you
severed your ACL you need to go
take five days rice you know rest ice
all that stuff I can't do that I've got
to be in the Octagon at two o'clock this
afternoon
so I went the Octagon on one leg I did
it all in one leg until you see
partially through the show they brought
me a brace and you see it on the outside
of my leg so I did three shows in a row
on one leg and you might say well why
why not listen to the doctor do that I'm
not fighting these Warriors are fighting
they're putting their Blood Sweat and
Tears in the line okay I'm the announcer
I blew my ACL all right okay I mean I'm
not like a football player being carted
off the field but I got the same entry I
can go in there and do this that's my
dedication that's my passion I'm like
Dana said you have to shoot me to keep
you out of the octane but frankly he's
correct and I hope I never get shot so
let's go
um all right are there Vegas odds on
whether or not you're gonna jump when
when you say it's time maybe when I stop
jumping for a while because I never had
this ACL fixed right where I had this
fixed I didn't have this fix and there
was a reason
um my mother uh
was had pneumonia and um you know she's
everything to me and um her lung
collapsed and I had to get her home in
hospice and I didn't want to be wrapped
up not being able to take care of my mom
okay so that lasted for a while they
told me she was gonna die and I was
going to Brazil the doctors called me
and they said she was going to die that
night or die in two weeks and they
wanted to put morphine in her and I said
don't you dare do that because she'll be
dead in three or four days I I knew
enough about that to know that
um and then I got her home and home
hospice and they said the morphine's in
the fridge if whatever hits the fan so I
wanted to be there for my mom
as God is my witness and everything else
they call me two months later and they
graduated my mother out of hospice the
lung the doctor said would never come
back came back
you know she's 94 years old now
beautiful smiling and uh I'm fine I can
live without my ACL I got my mom you
know so I don't play soccer and I don't
serve big waves anymore otherwise I jump
now I do all that stuff yeah thank God
because I train I train to do it I was
um
I think it was 282 and I was watching I
said I said to whoever I was watching is
he gonna jump and there was a jump maybe
not I mean I used to really go up I
would get like three four feet of air
right I mean a little
hopes yeah I'm still being I gotta land
with both feet you know I'm sick of
rehab I don't want any more rehab but
there's not always even a hop sometimes
there's there's no there's no hop well
I'll do it in different ways but I'll
create it and I'll create the excitement
for it oh yeah I'm not suggesting that
you don't no no no I gotta do I I never
know what I'm gonna do till I do it I
don't rehearse I don't go in the shower
and go you know chocolates
you know they send us sound files and we
we know how to say the name but I don't
I don't rehearse anything I write my
cards you notice I don't look a lot of
my cards because I got it all in my head
when I get in there but when I feel the
energy of the crowd that's what gets me
going okay that's where it all comes
together so that's when I I'm ready to
go there's a rehearsal voice and there's
the organic
your voice and I want to be organic you
know is it
and to answer your question yes they
used to take there have been like what
what color ties are going to wear right
people would email are you wearing a bow
tie or a regular tie wow I'm not going
to answer them because I know what
they're doing and then I I saw one of
the bets you know what uh bow tie or
whatever and I thought oh I'll put 10
000 on this right now no maximum bet 50
bucks oh really so but yeah they've done
your what color shirt you know I guess I
the UK's son wrote an article which
cracked me up because I have this
amazing Taylor uh King and Bay out of
Toronto Canada and they make these One
of a Kind Roger card silk jackets that
I'll dress up for the shows and stuff
and they called me a fashionista right
which cracks me up I mean who am I
kidding you know I think it's fair to
say well thank you bathing suit by day
tuxedo By Night Man For All Seasons man
for all reasons whatever you're gonna
love it
um we heard at one point that there was
a speculation that there was a was it a
curse if a fighter fist bumps you what
does it do is
what if you really go down to it well
first off you know uh DC Cormier said
yeah at one point that but not now if
you look at it and that's just you know
perception is reality okay right first
off I never instigate the fist bump
That's The Fighter coming to me right
okay I'll get in their space they
respect me enough to do that because I
want to give them every chance I can to
get them going you know they'll come to
me it's it's it's crazy some of the
things that happen I love it
but I never stay at the fist bomb they
do it and sure Fighters have lost it
fist but me but many many have won right
I paid I I heard about that and then
started paying attention to it and then
and clearly for the last number of years
there's nothing to that no there's
nothing to that it is safe to fist bump
the buff hell yeah yeah man we were we
were recording one of these um UFC watch
party shows for uh Fight Pass and my
buddy Chris Pontius from Jackass
he's so naturally [ __ ] funny and I
don't know where Pony says wow is he
aptly named Bruce Buffer is ripped
well you can't see that through the
tuxedo but I have my good days
it's fantastic out of all the ufcs
you've done which UFC star has had the
loudest cheer for when they walk out to
the Octagon you know it's it's like
asking me what the greatest fight the
greatest fighter is so hard because
obviously you're in Ireland and I would
say Conor McGregor walking out you know
in Ireland Ireland you can just be
anybody and walk out and they go crazy
they just love fights they love fights
in the UK but Conor McGregor definitely
gets at his Heyday a huge huge pop
George Saint Pierre in Canada huge huge
pop the Brazilian greats that have
fought in Brazil you know every
Arena every city has its own flavor
but they love their Fighters you know
it's really hard to pinpoint the one
that is the biggest I mean right now you
have patty pimla coming out yeah people
people love Patty it's crazy the the uh
were you there for Cheeto Vera versus
Dominic Cruz in San Diego no I was not I
did not do that show that was a joke
yeah
um because we were there and I think
that the fight had just ended but they
were about to
um announce the you know the the results
Hattie pimlic comes out into the into
the argument he's just standing in the
corner of the Arena he's not on the
Jumbotron there's activity going on
inside the Octagon the entire Arena
starts chanting oh Patty you're the bat
I mean
that's not him in Liverpool that's him
in San Diego San Diego you know there
are certain Fighters certain
entertainers that have what we call what
I call the hit Factor yeah right I mean
the Conor McGregor is the Ronda rouseys
the Patty pinlets with respect to all
the great Fighters men and women that
are in that walk in to put their Blood
Sweat and Tears in the line
but certain people have a larger organic
marketing power in the way they carry
themselves you know and um that's what
happens it comes along I know in Brazil
you know they're so dedicated like when
we go to Rio in January they'll probably
be anywhere from five to ten thousand
people at the weigh-in and then when I
walk out before the first fight even
happens the Arenas can easily be half or
more full
and me I'm not the fighter the show's
not about me I walk out they go out of
their minds I have to go in the octagon
and you know polite I want to go in the
Octagon to politely bow hey the show's
about to begin you know right it's like
the Gladiator you know are you not
entertained I mean let's get this thing
going what do they say in in Brazil they
chant like you're gonna die oh God I'm
not sure about that one it's something
it's something that they chant in
Portuguese and it translates to
something like I'm gonna say forever
the person who's fighting the Brazilian
fighter they say yeah oh yeah if it's a
non-brazilian fighter then maybe have
you know what I can answer that question
when I get back in January because I'll
I'll get that one figured out for you
but I remember in about 2003 because I
didn't start off saying the trademark
it's time you know which I have
trademarked and all
um I started saying that later on
because I was never phrase driven to me
it was not what I say it's how I'm going
to say it I wanted to work on my style
which I explained earlier but when I did
its time
um because I felt hey the fans have been
here for five six hours the Fighter's
been training for eight to ten weeks
I've been announcing now that you know
this whole show it comes culminates into
this Main Event it's time this is what
it all comes down to this is truly the
moment we've all been waiting for it's
unbelievable and it comes from the
morning every day I would wake up and
slap my face and say it's time to have a
great day and that's where that all
comes from so my own little thing
um I'll give you a thousand dollars if
by the time the end of this interview
you can come up with one line that I
can't put its timer in front or behind
and make work and don't even try because
so but I'll do it I'll give you I'll
give you a thousand bucks before we
leave today but um not like you need it
Stevo yeah yes Steve uh he he what do
you you do it every every fight you oh
my girl and I
died ritual really we you can dream can
you do it for us now
we love it so much yeah I'm honored by
that I'm humbly honored I thank you so
much that makes everything worthwhile to
me I'm in respect to that job that
beautiful job I have and Performing but
um what I was going to tell you in 2003
when I was in Brazil
I did it and I don't I don't hear the
audience and you'll understand this when
I'm in there doing my thing I'm in the
Fighter's eyes okay that's about me and
the fighter it's about the fighter right
now right I block everything out I'm
there for them right so I walk out of
the octagon and I heard a little
something and then uh sister around the
great uh cut man comes up to me goes
buff did you hear that I go what he goes
everybody in the arena repeated it with
you and held it with you as long as
possible great now I hear this is the
moment you've all been waiting for hey
now you know this is the main event and
it's all it's so it's such a compliment
it's like it's a high that I can have
that effect and people enjoy that and I
say this very humbly but it makes
everything work but at that point in
Brazil That's when I knew its time was
taken off yeah for sure let's see your
stuff where they've got here well I'll
preface by saying I've been a marketer
my whole life and I come from the school
of Don't Shoot to you see the whites of
their eyes because I could I've had
product and represented products in the
past but now it's time and I've been
working on these for two years but
here's I'm going to show you what I'm
about to come out with right now this is
my bourbon there you go puncher's chance
bourbon right you know one punch can
change your life the whole bit this is
the sweet nectar of the bourbon Gods
I've won six gold medals uh Burma
spectator just called the top five best
sipping bourbon in America at its price
range wow I came out with a 12 year
Reserve I just came out with the left
cross a 14-year reserve and a single
barrel version coming out this is 90
proof I have a barrel version that's 116
proof anyway there's you can go to
puncher's chance bourbon.com and see
everything order but it's in stores all
over the United States but this is one
of the newest fastest growing highest
rated Bourbons in America I'm really
proud I'm going to show Connor how to do
it the proper way
God I'm sorry I got to bust your balls a
little bit so you know we're all there's
room for everybody success Breeze
competition and competition breed
success I never worry about any of that
but I'm bringing this for you okay okay
how long did that take you to make
we started on this roughly two and a
half years ago I was approached by a
tequila company and a kashasa run
company out of Brazil and I didn't like
the business Acumen I didn't like the
product it didn't taste good and I will
not represent anything unless I believe
in it so this it truly is amazing it
mixes well I like it straight sipping
but it's it's awesome the bottles we
have made in France the gold medals we
won were three for design of the bottle
three for Taste and we're getting rave
reviews on our 14-year Reserve that came
out but very very proud of the great
business to be in cool works great
candidly we're both uh sober nerds
servers so we're both sober sober guys I
know I know that but you're still
getting the bottles yeah we love it now
this I'd like you to open if you want
but I have I'm coming out with my line
of toiletries and this is the it's time
cologne oh I love that and Scott can you
grab our toiletries back there
I believe we have a something for
from Bruce right there
Scott
butt wipes
oh butt wipes geez butt waves for your
butthole oh Stevo's butt white so that's
cracks me up okay Steve I will think
about you every time I go to the
bathroom you got it this is great I uh
It's Time by Bruce Buffer eau de parfum
fantastic let me pop this open I'll show
you everything
this is gonna be uh it's already selling
in Europe that's gonna be in 40
countries all around the world along
with a line of toiletries that I have
coming out which is
like body spray moisturizer all that
stuff so you can start off your morning
you can smell like buff
[Music]
and uh for as I oops sorry because I
always like to say hashtag buff life you
know that's my yeah
or Stevo life
check it out
and how long has this been uh
we we just started in Europe uh in the
last couple months and but it's going to
be in America starting in February March
uh be for sale everywhere
um I'm gonna wear this all the time
foreign
and women love it too because it's it's
got that subtle scent to it it's very
sensual
however you want to do it
yeah you don't want to overdo it don't
overdo it no but it's hard to overdo
that all right
you got that I'm getting a boner dude
yeah
yeah and then there'll be other things
like you know soap on a rope oh soap on
a rope this time
oh moisturizer body wash facial wash
it's all coming out it's okay now I am
in and here's I think you're gonna like
this this is going to be
I'm so excited about this okay this is
the most natural energy drink made
there's no terrain no sugar no anything
it's got wolf Berry it's got amino acids
vitamin B's this is something you can
drink three four cans of a day with no
crash a lot of the energy drinks have
taurine and stuff in them which is not
always the best thing for the body but
this is all natural even the man that
heads through Sada the test the fighters
he loves this so this is my it's time
energy drink and I wonder if this is
going to be a series of nutritional
products that are coming out too so all
this is coming out in 2023. we're making
a little sweeter than that version but
that's our initial one
sweeter than that this is great yep it's
all there for you babe
Bruce Buffer oh man unbelievable
I like what a great time to to catch you
with all this fun new stuff coming out
yeah well you know like I said and
everything in business hey Wendy there
you go oh I love that I love that you uh
you asked is that Wendy when you saw her
yeah has she been to a UFC should have
been the UFC fight she's been to the
Apex yeah yeah but I don't think you
bring a dog into the arena yeah she's
never been inside the Arenas but man
I've gone to Vegas and had the fertittas
put me up in Red Rock and these crazy oh
those sweets they have Red Rocker
awesome oh my gosh so cool I love that
place it's ridiculous and when I show up
they've got
balls and beds and treats and everything
for women with their name on it petite
is a Class Act Dana's a Class Act you
know they take good care it's a really
good care I knew when they bought the
UFC I got a call from the owner Robert
Meyer where she goes I got some good
news and bad news what's the bad news
because I sold the UFC
what's the good news because where
they're keeping you and John Big John
McCarthy that's cool great and then I
went to dinner I was at a boxing event
in the fertittas and Dana took uh John
me and some others out and I could see
the passion in them and they put Opus
One on the table and I go I can't wait
to work for those people what was once
in the finest red wines you can drink
just Class Act all the way and it was
just it was we were we were almost gone
we were going to be taking off the air I
mean this sport was actually almost
gonna die yeah you know if it wasn't for
them Dana and the protein Brothers
brought us back to life if if I heard
you correctly and if I understand the
history Dana and the fertitas bought the
UFC for 2 million they bought it for 2
million and sold it for 4.2 billion
right had I considering the businessman
that I like to think I am
um one point share was 20 000 when they
bought it I don't think they would have
sold it I actually thought back then as
saying hey I'll give you 50 Grand just
give me one point because I really
believe in this that one point was worth
42 million dollars when they sold it wow
we had a Matchmaker that actually did
quite well from the sale whatever his
agreement was he was gone like the next
week he retired wow for sure can you
think of a better CEO for the UFC than
Dana White I mean no you know Dana is
what I call a Maverick right walks to
his own tune yep uh the face of this of
this UFC if not the face of the sport to
a large extent with everything he's done
his passion I mean the man's worth God
knows what half billion more dollars I
mean that's none of my business but
let's be real he's worth every penny
anybody could ever dream of and he's
still busts his buns and his passion
every day developing you know the slap
fight now or doing the contender series
The Man doesn't stop he's incredible and
he'll stop and talk to you and like I'll
sit next to him if we go to UFC fight
and he's like hitting my leg like we're
like we're buddies and I'm just like I
admire that because he's just like that
with everybody yeah and you've got to
appreciate that you really have to agree
to them yeah and and to the point where
you say the face of the whole sport
there's something where I think is
pretty telling that during my my Live
Comedy Show I have one section of it for
this tour that I've been on where it's
about me trying to get cauliflower here
and the bit starts out by me saying
I became buddies with the ultimate
fighting Legend Chuck Liddell and
I think about that and how significant
it is it's not that I you know that I'm
doing that as a favor to the UFC it's
just that it's more uh
it's it it's more resonant it it
connects more it's more easily
understood to say the ultimate fighting
Legend than if I were to say the MMA
Legend absolutely like the average
person is not gonna compute MMA Legend
but if I say the ultimate fighting
Legend people know exactly what it is
and that means that the UFC is in fact
bigger than MMA well it's like it's not
it's not uh tissue it's Kleenex it's not
a copier it's a Xerox right it's not MMA
it's UFC I mean people come up and
they'll say oh well my son is a UFC
fighter what's your son's name with all
respect and everybody in the UFC I mean
your son's a mixed martial artist okay
that's where all that comes in those are
great examples yeah yeah which is pretty
incredible yeah when you talk about
comedy okay let me tell you something
about comedy I have been going to The
Comedy Store since 1977 I think it was
when it opened back when they had a
Westwood Comedy Store and David
Letterman was the host and the doorman
every night okay wow I saw everybody
from Robin Williams to Richard Pryor do
you name it how they'll drop in I go on
and on and on I saw Jim Carrey at 18 and
I was so blown away I said this guy's
going to be huge someday what a rubber
man as amazing as it was Andrew Dice
Clay when he was sleeping on Mitzi
Shores couch I love stand-up comedy I'm
a frustrated stand-up comic to an extent
I can only tackle so many things in my
life
um but great date night it was my Friday
date night I mean the comics definitely
added a lot of flair to the date night
right and it's just a great day great
dinner the whole bit so I started my
comedy show the it's time
um
and I had it for the first time at the
Laugh Factory where I hosted it
you know Tony Hinchcliffe I had a bunch
of different guys that you would know
and and girls and um I would come out in
between and do my bit and all and
um I loved it I was going to do it once
a month and The Comedy Store was gonna
let me start in the small room and build
up to the big room the coveted him
right so I never I've never done another
one but it wasn't again that's not in
any way about the money I just think
what a great night what a fun night sure
you know I love stand-up comedy Stevo
yeah I I love it but my next thing that
I that I say after the chuck wood I said
like most ultimate fighters Chuck's ears
appear to be highly allergic to his head
I always enjoy that and and speaking of
the the UFC fans you were you were
saying how how passionate they are
like most recently we're we're seeing
evidence of how educated they are about
fighting about how like uh it used to be
a concern that the grappling was just
kind of over their heads and you know
and now like now they're really really
uh just demonstrating this Highly
Educated understanding of what's going
on in all the grappling Transitions and
it's it's amazing it's amazing and you
know the grappling a lot of times people
will not sit there and watch grappling
for six hours they want to gotta get the
stand up and striking I remember when
the potatoes had one of the biggest
shows ever 37 and a half and it was just
grappling the whole night and no offense
but it wasn't the most exciting show
right
um then they've created the stand-up
rule with nothing if they're dormant for
like 30 seconds stand them up let them
go at it which actually made the whole
sport even more exciting but the beauty
of it is that they are educating
themselves you know you see uh girls
come two and three girls alone without
their boyfriend right they know the
moves they know the fights that's when
you get that you've got to captured and
raptured audience
they're diehards you know they live and
breathe UFC it's awesome yeah it's
really really awesome it's great to have
it first class seat on this rocket ship
going uphill it's unbelievable
um let me ask let me ask you this about
um you know people talk about open
scoring and I think everybody agrees
open scoring would be a terrible idea
because then you're going to have
Fighters going into third rounds just
lazy
um no nobody wants open scoring net no
fans anyways
um but what do you think about going
into each round
if they've shared the live odds on the
screen and how the live odds fluctuated
the live odds of betting yeah
uh you know they're doing that now
anyway so I don't think it would make
any difference they'd give you the the
who's the favorite they give you the the
beginning of the fight they don't always
give you the the live odds at the
beginning of the second and third round
or Championship rounds if they apply
probably part of the I mean I would have
no problem with it but I I think it
might involve maybe some of the
fighter scoring call it legality call it
whatever they don't want any influence
on the judges they don't want any
influence on whatever
um but
considering they're showing the odds at
the beginning of the fight I don't think
it would be an issue because the judges
are not sitting there watching this on
TV sometimes they don't want what those
are monitors right but that's not the
actual practice my knowledge is not the
actual show right I think so and
sometimes this is the actual show then
they shouldn't do that
sometimes they do uh post that you know
they'll put on the screen the live odds
sometimes let's say the commentators
will say it I I just I'm always
fascinated by it it makes them fight
more interesting for me if I know what
the odds are and if I know how the odds
are changing but remember too when when
in football and everything when they set
the odds and you hear that you know
Brady is a five-point favorite but then
it goes and swings where suddenly he's a
six point favorite or a four-point favor
that's because the betting is going one
way or the other right it's really not
the reality of the situation okay okay
that's where that could sway that issue
a little bit all right then then uh that
that's a fair point now my my last
question
um you can ask more what do you think
about if in the inspection area where
they're where they're checking the
Fighter's cup the mouthpiece they're
putting the Vaseline on their face
um if the in the inspection area the
fighter was standing on a scale so that
you would know as the fighter enters the
Octagon for the fight what they weighed
how much weight they had put on since
the weigh-in
I don't particularly care for that okay
um only because the fact that it kind of
takes away
um from the remember a lot of the
viewing eyes watching the TV are not
educated like you are they're watching
knowing that it's a 155 pound
lightweight division it's a 205 pound
light heavyweight division
and to think that a fighter came in man
or woman and they as many times do
there'll be 15 20 pounds heavier the
next night it's an interesting thing but
right now my initial reaction is I'm
torn on that I don't know if that's
right I think let's just keep it
lightweight walk in but there's many
times I'm standing in the octagon with
the referee and I go
that's a 155 pound man just walked in I
mean you know they'll walk in weighing
175 you know it's like that's a big
lightweight that's right big
middleweight
um I I I can see your point why do you
want to see that I just think it's
interesting I think you can tell just
looking at them they don't weigh 155 or
they don't weigh 205 or Derek Lewis have
got down to 260 is not weighing 260 when
he walked in on Fight Night you know
that kind of thing yeah
um I I I just think it's interesting you
know I want to say it too because I
think that the the there's gonna be
super Die Hard UFC fans listening to
this and I've said uh how you know I I
lost contact with Jon Jones but Jon
Jones and I have been reunited very cool
I just I just saw him uh in Albuquerque
this past week and um like how's he
looking it's huge yeah huge he'll take
about the two three years he spent
putting on this 50 pounds or whatever
reason like 230 240. yeah yeah it's
probably about 2 40 I would think dude
yeah he told me to jump on on his back
for a photo and and uh there was no
issue there he's amazing I'm sorry to
say he hasn't fought for so long God
knows I wanted to think I don't want to
think about the millions of dollars that
he's not been able to earn you know
during that time period but he's going
to come back make a ton of money and and
make a ton more and um
we'll see how he does he's going to do
amazing win or lose it's Jon Jones he's
coming back he's a huge attractive
there's not a single UFC fan including
me as the announcer and I'm a fan first
before I ever pick up that microphone
that I can't wait to see Jon Jones walk
back in the octagon it's going to be
huge I mean I I was driving
the last time he fought I was driving
and I drove past the Staple Center and I
they had at the yard house I pulled over
parked my car in valet and then watched
it on the TV because I saw as I was
driving by on the TV that's how much of
a fan of Jon Jones I am yeah it's it's
awesome and I'm not just saying this
Steve you smell fantastic
smells
like
baby
I'm wearing it's time dude it's time by
Bruce Buffer dude this time in a
Bluetooth game over dude get get used to
it it's time to it's time to go home and
make a baby yeah
man what an honor Bruce thank you so
much for doing this thank you thank you
for the gifts thank you for all the love
thank you for the the phenomenon the the
the UFC I mean being a fan of the USC is
so exciting there's not a live event
that I could possibly imagine attending
that's more exciting than the than the
UFC and there's nothing I love more than
showing up
for the very first fight pass Prelude
which you do yeah which you do yeah I I
love it the the first time you guys met
and I think it was at the airport and I
mean I don't remember the date but you
were flying to it Chicago yeah and you
were flying to Atlantic City and you're
like dude you want to come to Atlantic
City yeah we're like oh [ __ ] we're gonna
be you know but that that whatever day
that was that was you know I actually
saw the picture in my iPhone memory just
a little while ago okay cool yeah
because that was the first time you guys
met yeah dude yeah well I'm listening
I've been a fan of yours forever and she
blew me away it's crazy well thank you
you're not gonna get out of here and not
have to do anything nuts and that's so
cool
if you want to live another day man
thank you Bruce thank you friendship
appreciate everything likewise yeah
thank you thank you too pleasure and
thank you everybody watching thank you
for UFC fans
God bless you all happy holidays
there you have it folks a legend Bruce
Buffer man can't say enough good stuff
about that guy and um I'm wearing his
cologne right now love it I pounded his
energy drink loved it and uh I'm not
drinking the whiskey okay
um and uh other than that man well what
a year 2022 this would be the last one
or there's one yeah there's one more
yeah crazy here man thank you for being
a part of it I love you guys